Boulton Underwood gives Heather her  first kiss kissing Heather was magical  while Elise makes a sudden exit this is  my worst nightmare  the 31 year old makeup artist and fan  favorites suddenly left the competition  on Monday night's episode after a  tearful confrontation with Colton  competition got intense  after Elise's surprising exit Hanabi ate  a bug whole things heat it up between  Colton and Cassie I'm crazy about you  [Music]  he told me that he was crazy about me  like my gut my heart is telling us to go  off and major drama erupted between  Nicole and Anika you are a liar Nicole  you are a liar you're putting words in  my mouth and you like targeting me I  would close her waist at times like this  kind of like petty trauma 26 year old a  former NFL star stormed off sending us  into next week  unsure whether the two are safe you're  not here at America  [Music]